yo tout le monde sait squeeze
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
chevalerie médiévale warfare un jeu où
finalement on joue une sorte de soldats
très viril un donc peu importe même si
on n'a pas une muscle a en fait on peut
quand même être force dans le jeu donc
ce jeu a été créé pour moi finalement je
prendre une bonne grosse tâche de
bûcheron on garde assiste à des scènes
de dingue
attention lui il est annulé à nouart est
mon gala rythme et j'ai d'accord très
bien cet homme est juste le boss du gain
nous te saluons jean-hervé motard un
homme qui lancent des deux lacs où je me
casse tête etc [ __ ] à lens pierre
alaux jours au lance-pierre aller au
dessus au lance pierre mais se prend
pour un ninja
ok ok ok ok ok pourquoi dès que je fais
une bonne action juste après je meurs
pourquoi ok ce qu'on va monter autres
cette pierre pour lancer nos et
attention je suis extrêmement menaçant
puisque j'ai un lance pierre wat mais
c'est normal qu'il a dit what the fuck
mais qu'il arrive une coupe la tête
d'une manière totalement basiques comme
si et qui faisait une tarte aux poireaux
un problème n'est pas de malaise ce mec
sa chatte
regardez regardez comment met on va bien
tous les faire chier regarder hop voilà
et maintenant on rentre dans le tas à
chiba qui se marchent grand chose au
letzigrund
ok très bien on a fait un génocide
as confère un ripper de cette
merveilleuse action
c'était incroyable un des plus beaux
jours de ma vie de soldat ou one of them
mais vous avez vu son mets tes passions
herbe mais son arme fait vingt mètres
oui bah forcément je perds ton a fait 20
matchs avec toi tu es à moi tu es à moi
tu aurais dit ah oui tu es jacques est
ce qu'il ya un casque hi qu'est ce qui a
donc cet homme dans son bras avait
finalement des copeaux de bois très vite
oula oula la ville en elle je m'en vais
chercher du bois alors lis pas tout seul
quels mets toi je dois contrôler la
testostérone ok les gens techniques
ninja horaire ça a marché
qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'est ce qui fait
l'homme est une boîte de conserve sur la
tête qu'est ce qu'il fait qu'est-ce-qui
d'accord très bien ok actuellement on
est avant dernier s'est pas trop mal je
trouve une certaine maîtrise très bien
donc toi tu es une sorte de bûcheron du
hockey up et là on fonce dans le tas
mais lui regarde sur norbert tiens tiens
je nomme piste ya peut-être un peu trop
emballé on passe en mode en mode sniper
ok voilà c'est parti mon dieu il a tapé
une esquive dos ok je loupais on s'en
bat les steaks tu te tiens tu croyais
quand même des fourchettes a à perdre et
le lui la lui là bas ils veulent notre
mort en tant que rechargement et
si on n'est pas d'accord d'accord ok les
pièces me refasse bonnes attentions
j'ai des couteaux de lancer ou bien
battre d'un bat tous au
c'est aujourd'hui que nous nous
recueillons pour la mort de jean louis
david qui s'est pris à peu près de 10000
couteau dans son corps voilà comme ça en
fait les morts ici d'accord alors lui il
rentre dans la faille qui rentrent comme
ça non pas entre les deux au revoir je
demandai je m'enfuis voilà je vais boire
de l'eau regardez ça c'est la technique
zigzag
ok je m'enfuis bombe à l'estac jeu court
aux halles est ce qu'on le fait courir
valeur tels pas jouer à chat qu'est-ce
qui se passe dégage toi ok ah c'est pas
grave
allez continue de te battre il traite
une main et il traite une un bouquet tu
tombes pour et du ton rock et regardez
regardez regardez
ah non en août et là on fait la
technique je t'attends monde en faux
culs
telle une épée devant m ah non ça
t'apprendra à me toucher
tu sais pas qui je suis moi rien des
regards des commandes et des bâtards
aller voilà battez-vous moi j'arrive
quoique après tu viens de battre
d'accord ok ils sont comme ça dans le
jeu à les rejoindre dans l'écran de
fumée se boire tort ok on a eu le
dernier mot
allez ce attention à tout ce que tu fais
jeune homme attention at un truc là ok
c'est un bouclier
ok peut-être j'adopte de l'as lens l'as
lens est adoptée au wat a fauté mais
what
ok donc sa tm ec statut non mais sans
dec les mecs ok d'accord alors heureux
alors heureux au jour un jeu fun blanc
comme sur un toit parce qu'on veut
trouve tuer des gens regardez regardez à
mais herbe
o o et la violence suivant à ok on va se
cacher derrière le poteau wata hausse la
déception de mourir j'ai quitté ma loge
pour complet pour détrôner des mecs qui
salue tout va bien d'accord donc les
spots sont extrêmement bien fait danger
vite appelé la sage femme inquiétez pas
tout va bien ce pas votre bébé études
friche ok alors le gros problème avec
leurs mallettes en fait c'est quand tu
recherches
finalement parce qu'il ya des gens à des
gros marc barr qui font ça voilà il va
recharger ils font des recherches
attention au type de campagne bouge toi
j'écoute watts inscrits pour ce mec
c'est un streamer à la violence du mec
je suis choquée quoi donc les huit
géants va se faire viens là tu fais quoi
mon gars
attends mais c'est un [ __ ] tu as mac
bonjour comment allez vous tu sors de
chez toi comme ça tu vas aller acheter
une baguette et tu te prends ça dans la
face quoi sages-femmes vie tu es un mec
là bas qui campera garder le lait chaud
pour un méchoui toi grosse ambiance ici
sa salle à ce que tu veux faire une
brochette de chamallows ça c'est thomas
agressé par quelqu'un alors que
j'expliquais simplement quelque chose de
bon à la une tête en moins suivants o o
avant moi oh oh là à lui lui les
perfides regardez il ya une petite
d'agde
donc on croit qu'il est nul après fait
il est super malin bah oui bah voilà ok
maintenant tdm je viens vous couper la
tête tout à tuer mon ami ok donc j'ai
pris un coup perdu et ce qu'on est
d'accord a sur le coeur
et si ce sport tas ok vous salue est ce
que c'est normal ça les mecs on vous
êtes ensemble et garin on est ensemble
1 je sais que tu as une testicules sur
la tête mais tu me regardes pas comme ça
si je me fais que je me fais un lequel
lui allait lui 3 à 3 contre 1 les gars
c'est bon on est on est très fair play
voilà
[Musique]
ok attendez attendez attendez les gars
légal et gâteaux on devait tester pour
rien le 3 contre les mails les meilleurs
boga à aller je te fais je te fais la
bise aller à tout à l'heure
allez tu vas hamada ben ouais je te fais
la bise toi par contre on se devait non
non il me suit il suis arrivé et voilà
les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette
vidéo j'espère que ça vous aura plu
cette virilité intense et transpiration
je souhaite de bien profiter du réseau
vacances on se retrouve dimanche soir
dans une nouvelle vidéo que tout le
monde puisse et à bientôt
[Musique]